boa tarde a todos em primeiro lugar é de
facto o privilégio estar aqui parece que
finalmente uma boa ideia minha vida é o
conto sempre maioria está organizando um
telefone com vida estar aqui neste paulo
então peço a todos uma enorme salva de
palmas pra mim que não faz muito tempo
desde vida
obrigado obrigado e agora vai em 2009
porta voz
é o título da minha é a apresentação que
hoje está aí até à exaustão
ele tem a cara do motel que é o cesar
depois de ver as opções que eu chamava
por ele eu fazia isso
portanto tite pelo caminho encontrei
alguns vídeos sobre o terek em portugal
é o ricardo os prédios espero que um dia
eu vejo no vídeo e identifica que há
três tipos de apresentadores do inter ex
ac os da claque de portugal crise para
nós há 500 anos muito bons
o vasco da gama e agora como nós
tínhamos mesmo espaço teve que ser outra
vez aos 54 portugal
depois aos da igreja universal do reino
empreendedorismo
parece que temos um problema na perna é
primo empresa ea dor passa o
empreendedorismo é que portugal vá se de
críticas de empreendorismo e por último
ele identifica um terceiro tipo eu
assino 34 portugal eu empreendorismo e
os tipos do que o brasil não lembro bom
adiante e eu vou tentar não queria que
nenhum destes eróticos portanto vai
entrar pra ter uma idéia é que acho que
vale a pena ser protelada
não pretendo que sigam essa idéia é
apenas ao que eu ia pisar em um dia e
neste momento porém prata que tu ouves
funciona ou não ou não funciona
entretanto lembrar qualquer outro tipo
aqui vou dizer é os tipos do jack o
estripador que pato fez um sonho
ok segundo seu sonho nem consulta de 30
pessoas mas o que é importante é que as
flores não tivesse um sonho não empatava
o emprego e pensar faz nem pra mim vou
largar um emprego um sonho streep a
criança em espanha levou praí
identifiquem os três tipos o meu tipo m
vai topar a teoria da história dela para
a prova um signo não amigos como sempre
de vida e vida continua ea idéia surgiu
porque esta senhora que está já agora é
começar euro
aí as tecnologias de informação e
telecomunicações diz que em 2020 vai
fazer 2 milhões de vagas por preencher
em tecnologia da informação portanto são
cadeiras vazias são empregos existentes
mas não há pessoas com competências
preocupar
essas vagas portanto filme et jobs for
the boys
quando falamos em desemprego e criar
nova em desemprego em algumas áreas
assim em outras por outro lado o senhor
do eurostat
dizem que hoje a 3.6 milhões de jovens
desempregados na europa cuidados entre
os de 25 anos dois milhões de lugares a
preencher o acesso àquela secretaria
limpinha uma das gavetas paraguaias o
computador e pronto lá 3.6 milhões de
jovens desempregados bota faca na bota
foi estranho estranho é também se nós
conseguimos converter desempregados
qualificados a empregados qualificados
num curto espaço de tempo três meses
possivelmente seriam mais felizes no fim
deste este período
e foi assim que começou a surgir bom
temos que montar uma máquina que
consegue criar aqui por ser assim
mecanismos para entrar desempregado
quando ficava sair empregado codificado
em 3 a 3 mesmo esta loja que daí ver e e
que nós vamos tentar implementar desde o
início do ano então estamos a pensar bom
que ingredientes é que nós precisamos
pinga e então nós precisamos para
conseguir fazer este milagre a
organizações públicas e tentar fazer
isso há algum tempo e por falar em
números como 10% sempre parece agora nas
férias é 14% sempre daqui em diante nós
precisamos então lembramos vamos ter e
vamos ter que tirar tudo aqui seguida as
pessoas como colher e meia juninho de
cabeça levando uma colher e ramon que o
youtube depois por lá um novo chip que
as pessoas consigam trabalhar em
tecnologias de informação
ok nós pensarmos bom
são os espíritos a nível nacional a
ênfase branco rocha que seguir as
pessoas
lembramos a papai noel um tipo de 900
anos são as moitas é conseguir que
entram em green minhas e saiu ramo tem
que ser um deles mas nunca fui como é
que entra ninguém sai um rambo um curto
espaço de tempo e isso eu só vim fazer
nós vamos ter que criar aqui parcerias
com as muitas que o som preto no branco
roche algum sentido como mel como é
óbvio e ninguém melhor do que o faço em
território também né nacional
depois o movimento que vimos o vídeo do
senhor que 95 já que é pessoa de
acreditar nos fundamentos que o ensino
está completamente desatualizado
a imagem mostra que vemos é uma imagem
na sala de aula na era da função
industrial
como vocês podem ver nos dias hoje 1 do
mundo todo estão guarda roupa talvez nós
temos um quadro com giz usa sua inovação
é incrível
o powerpoint
o resto é as mesas no mesmo formato da
campanha e agora conhecer o professor eo
aluno é uma falácia e alguns já ouvi e
outros todos no facebook
ok tá era assim que a educação era feita
mas na altura é simples vamos apertar
parafuso esquerda todos simulavam optar
pelo futebol acho que até um filme sobre
ele só tem que brincar um pouco com com
estadual de ensino está completamente
desatualizado e prova disso é que os nós
estamos a fabricar pessoas para o
desemprego muitos dos cursos fundaram ao
desemprego
o senhor que está uma palestra é não ter
ex igual a este
é porque eu conseguir um espaço de um
ano a partir de casa fazer cinco anos do
haiti
white uma das universidades mais
prestigiadas do mundo tanto que o prova
que hoje em dia estamos na era da
democratização da educação
mas se tiver um computador com ligação à
internet
eu consigo ter aulas com os melhores
produtos do mundo
o custo praticamente zero portanto é
nisso que é preciso deslocar uma
localização em concreto nem precisa ter
rios de dinheiro para conseguir ajudar o
haiti não têm acesso a toda esta
informação
o capitão se tiver capacidade de ser
autodidata e não conseguir automotivar
consegui ter acesso ao mesmo sistema de
ensino todos os outros que vivem naquela
geografia em em concreto nosso temos
como consultor o senhor alberto einstein
trabalhe conosco há algum tempo e os 90
anos ainda confirma que de facto eu
nunca quis ensinar seus alunos o que eu
queria era quando criar condições para
que os alunos aprendam ainda hoje
acreditamos no que o frio
nós achamos que levantem o trabalho de
que o projeto vocês fizeram na
universidade ensino secundário aluno com
o aluno era giríssimo não era bem menos
uns copos ir para casa de uns amigos uns
trabalhavam ou distribuíam mas o que é
certo é que nós nos divertíamos e
conseguimos até aprender durante esse
processo todos nós passarmos certamente
é por isto e nesse sentido nós a nossa
ideia é pensarmos assim bom era que as
suas dependências em umas com as outras
o piloto pedro roque como nós temos um
avião militar
chamamos os alunos recrutas ok
portanto nada recruta para recruta oito
recordes o que achamos que esse modelo é
muito mais divertido
as pessoas ainda pensam tecnologias é
uma coisa muito complexa e se é para
utilizar em portugal é dos países com
mais penetração de smartphones são
telemóveis no mundo é grande as novas
tecnologias nos fazer tecnologia ainda
há muitos que acham extremamente é
complicado
o gato que nós aqui vemos chamas escrete
é uma tecnologia desenvolvida pelo é
mike permite que crianças aprendam a
programar é fazer que os joguinhos quase
20 poetas do angry birds e e outros e
equipamentos
hoje é possível ensinar as pessoas a
programar usando técnicas e ferramentas
muito mais evoluídos do que há 20 anos
atrás
portanto não é um bicho de sete cabeças
e aprender a programar não é um bicho de
sete cabeças conseguir ter as
competências preocupar os detalhes 2
milhões de lugares que estão hoje
disponíveis numa escolha dos
ingredientes também achamos por bem bom
já vamos montar aqui esta máquina
vamos ter que ter mais conteúdo do que
apenas um gato que os créditos que
ensinar programar vamos ter que dar
alguma coisa você nada com ciências da
computação que este não foi horrível
então lembrar você vai poder usar
conteúdo de harward trazia árvore para
lisboa para o porto e para o óbito e dar
esses mesmos conteúdos e as nossas
pessoas muito bem então vamos fazer
juntamos esse conteúdo esse ingrediente
também aqui a nossa
a nossa máquina fruta em falta aqui o
ingrediente essencial que é algo que é
preponderante já hoje aqui falar sobre
isto que é bom eu já tô preparar as
pessoas do ponto de vista comportamental
com os militares já estão a preparar as
pessoas pobres e tecnológico com todos
estes conteúdos nós vamos buscar os
mesmos sítios
agora o que é importante é que a pessoa
consiga ir a entrevistas de emprego e
fazer um bom jogo e uma boa entrevista
de emprego
agora todos nós sabemos que a internet
está carregado de vídeo sobre como fazer
um ótimo entrevista de emprego é o
famoso ela vai ter pizza a explicar em
todo o lado passa a conhecer luciana
inovadora
o que tu dizes escolheu perguntar alguma
coisa tanto em formação está por todo
lado mas nós não conseguirmos de facto
mudar a forma como nós nos vendemos ou
não nos vendemos nesse sentido que nós
achamos com que nossa máquina que nós
estamos a montar transforma
desempregados empregados vai ter clima
equipe de vendas o que tem que fazer
essa equipe de vendas com essa equipe de
vendas a vender o nosso produto e que é
o nosso produto são as pessoas que estão
a qualificar nós pensamos bom tempo sem
uma equipe de vendedores que está
permanentemente importa importa dizer
sim para termos aqui o joão o carro e
claudia então precisamos nos conhecer os
fatos são os homens que tu precisas para
fazer o que o software que melhora a
atividade desta quinta conforme por
exemplo são as pessoas que precisam as
próprias cadeiras estão vagas de estágio
esperada procura profissionais são as
duas que precisa fazer o software possa
conseguir google por roger a outra marca
conhecida tanto software está por todo
lado e não tem pessoas de tantas aqui um
conjunto pessoas têm que tal um escort
que tu queres olha isso aqui é proativo
está aqui só problema nisto eu sei que é
relativo mas é cumpridor não escolhe
quem tudo desabou e daí o cartão traz
novas pessoas
deus pode acontecer eventualmente ficar
com alguma alguma delas
por último mas só queria que o
ingrediente que era fundamental que as
pessoas só devem pagar a sua juntava for
atingido
ou seja se no final nós não conseguimos
vender um emprego também não faz sentido
que as pessoas paguem por tudo
portanto temos aqui um museu para poder
compreender melhor imagine universidad
não vocês estudaram onde só pagariam
propina
de fato no final safin a trabalhar nessa
área pense um pouco fizeram professora
gerir de forma diferente se calhar a
secretaria e de forma diferente a todos
iam agir de forma diferente porque o seu
ordenado estava indexado ao resultado
senão as forças a power band passar pode
ser fácil conseguir que a pessoa tenha
competência para ter um emprego
se calhar não é tão fácil quanto e assim
criamos este museu também aqui na nossa
máquina do decom de reconversão e nesse
sentido nós temos dificuldade em reter e
categorizar o que estiver aqui eu já me
empresa significa porque não é
informação não é apenas educação
nós queremos apenas dizer país não é um
programa é normal formação de platéia
virtual é uma coisa completamente
diferente onde vens para cá para cumprir
ordens durante três meses aqui fazendo
nada a fazer
3 - não reclama já visto em algum lado
já ambiente não estar durante três meses
do kups no final tem o emprego e os
níveis de ansiedade aumentam substâncias
oficialmente mas tem que ter uma
mentalidade eu vou ser software
developer nem como legenda é figurativo
calma e você software developer nem que
o humor a tentar eu vou conseguir vou
adaptar a minha vida como se eu fosse
três meses para o afeganistão cumprir
missão da missão dada é missão cumprida
este o mais certo nós queremos nós
dizemos assim bom aqui da nossa máquina
não queremos 99% das pessoas
só queremos as pessoas já pensa só
pensam assim
o que tem potencial para pensar é é
assim e agora peço por favor para
passarem o vídeo preverem o que eu quero
dizer
como um organismo em imagens reais
são imagens reais do que aconteceu
recentemente
agora peço acenderem as luzes por favor
nomeadamente na na parte onde está o
público gostava de ver um pouco é para
todos perceberem que programaram não é
tão difícil quanto isso o programador e
alguém que resolve problemas no forma
eficaz e eficiente
eu vou dar um exemplo hoje aqui foi o
frio pesquisar no google demora
tipicamente sempre o mesmo tempo
independentemente da complexidade
enquanto pesquisam hoje não foi dito
quantas pessoas estão aqui na audiência
e nós vamos ajudar a organização recebe
quantas pessoas aqui estão hídrica três
formas um chamariz ao grito de conseguir
receber a primeira forma para vem
1234567 não tem previsto dois quatro
seis oito dez doze já em cortar plantado
tempo necessário
mesmo assim parece muito para devolver
todos possam ser rapidamente rápido até
montar agora cada um tem um número na
cabeça não caem e vão seguir a pessoa do
lado ou atrás e vão ficar com o número
que ela tá importante neste momento tem
um álbum fica com 2 é que eu pego número
semtas e depois repete em exercício em
curso tanto pt só quem tiver 12 e outro
tiver 21 passa a 4800 e fazem até ficar
em alguns pms cantinho e por isso menos
no mercado ontem o cara quando eu
crescer começa agora vá acontecer mas
não quando não custa nada
temos 15 segundos mas nas minhas férias
vamos lá falando apenas do número nome
mais nada
focas
ok estamos na reta final quem estiver
sentado por favor não emitem sons 83
pessoal e nossos números agora gosto
pessoal - número incerto mas tem 4 31 ou
alguém que não faz contas convencer vão
realizar identificamos o pai do nosso
problema é importante e deve dar o
número na casa dos cinquenta e poucos
não sei que o central portantes este
algoritmo funciona
as pessoas fazem as contas bem feitas
mas é verdade é verdade é que o tempo
que demorar contra sua gestão foi
manifestamente foi a última ordem de
grandeza de 50 e muito se quiser
assistir no estádio da luz o dólar com
quem mais tempo conseguimos saber qual
era a audiência estava bom tal como no
software às vezes avante a problemas têm
de ser resolvidos acontecer ainda bem
que está a acontecer prometeu mostrar
que essas coisas acontecem em um
algoritmo um programador e alguém que
pensa como é que eu vou resolver o
problema da forma mais eficiente e mais
eficaz
só quis mostrar que é possível se vocês
quiserem aprender em trazer a magia que
tem no bolso é que os jogos pelas
aplicações software que você tem em casa
né na televisão
nós aumentamos nosso projeto há dez
meses estamos neste momento em três
cidades
uma delas na cidade mas vou chamar se dá
também lisboa também sem óbitos
estamos no no porto não somos com o
cobrador fazia tudo e mais alguma coisa
desde limpar o chão é coordenar a
empresa neste mês dez colaboradores
cobradores já temos emprego a mais de 20
pessoas é e estamos já temos pessoas a
trabalhar em três eixos desenvolvimento
local está aqui incluído
contamos a 31 dezembro ter feito esse
trabalho com aproximadamente 100 pessoas
interessadas em que o que quer passar
empate vans
ok não estavam desativados ativas ajudem
a ativar portugal foi claramente
possível entender que nós cada um nós
deve liberar o seu futuro
se não consegue fazer sozinho apenas
empresas com idéias estão a tentar fazê
lo de forma assistida podem sempre ajuda
e lembrem-se de 2 milhões de empregos em
haidê
mas nem tudo alfa gripe mas foi isso
obrigado a todos